foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello hello
[Music]
um because not necessarily if you can
sell like
2 000 tickets at a club date
like your your Thursday Friday Saturday
that that's a you should say okay then I
can do a theater that's two thousand
seats but not necessarily because you're
going on sale for just that one night on
Saturday getting all people getting
people all in on one night getting all
those 2 000 people those two thousand
fans to go one night is a way different
story
isn't that interesting so now are we
doing a boring are we doing boring on
purpose stuff I feel like people would
want to know that the insides of doing
stand-up they do but there was no
context before you said any of that
stuff so nobody knows what you they do
I'm talking about clubs versus theaters
and when when comedians make the job for
jump from clubs to theaters
I wasn't listening you're welcome your
hair looks fantastic today okay I won't
touch it but why does it look so nice
you watched it I didn't watch it it
looks beautiful see that's what I'm
saying after if you don't watch it for
long enough it comes back around oh
really and it's beautiful I didn't know
that bring up my dates here so I could
plug them and then actually care about
them but that's beautiful beautiful hair
so I'll be in I'll be in Tulsa no but
that's really great you look great you
look great today and you know what I'm
kind of feeling like I look great too
you do you actually look great thanks
very much actually before we started I
first thing I said was that's a really
great shirt and you said what
uh I knew you'd like it uh-huh and I
said no you didn't I'm not predictable
and then what did you say I ever forget
what happened after that that was the
part you said uh yeah you're a
predictable [ __ ] oh yeah okay right so
I was mean but I would tell you this
yeah I had a uh Daydream give you have
Daydreams you know obviously you have we
have Daydreams and [ __ ] but I was
driving over here and I was thinking
Matt's gonna say he likes this shirt and
I'm gonna say and I daydreamed you I'll
give it to you you can have it you
didn't say that though no I know but and
and I and I was and I daydreamed me
giving it to you after the podcast and
you having it
and I don't think I'm gonna do that so
yeah that's what I daydreamed so you
date your Daydream self is like way
nicer than your real stuff yeah okay uh
yeah yeah but it's also way way worse
too because all Daydream sometimes just
that's something that's what I'm saying
it's usually my Daydream is usually
consist of me doing things that are not
as nice as I am in real life yeah I do
both but don't you also Daydream like
saving people's lives and stuff
yeah but that's not nice that's like so
I can be a hero you know you're not a
dream hero yeah you're not a dream hero
we could call that episode dream hero we
could do that
um I'm gonna speaking of selling tickets
and stuff speaking of Heroes speaking of
Heroes I'll be in San Diego on January
7th uh get your tickets there San Diego
chrysalia.com I got Brea Improv coming
up uh just some Club dates just just
just you know having some fun at some
Club dates Portland Oregon I'm gonna be
there Seattle Washington I got two shows
January 21st and January 22nd Seattle
Washington I can't wait to come to
McCall Hall Lakeland Florida and Daytona
and Jacksonville the 26th 27th and 28th
San Antonio Texas February 3rd and keep
it moving
Sugarland Texas New Orleans Providence
Rhode Island New York New York
Chicago Illinois Kansas City Springfield
Missouri anyway the list goes on
crystalia.com go get your tickets before
they sell out Austin almost sold out go
get your tickets and uh and that's that
now if you want to
uh subscribe to this super cult channel
that will be helpful it'll be really
great we're stuck at 596. now it seems
to me Matt I know that uh Chris should
definitely go to the thing right now
where we would do the hey if you want to
call in or whatever and he's not doing
it so if you haven't we just did it now
so if you have a question click the link
in the description below or go to watch
lifeline.com and if you want a
one-on-one advice sessions with Matt
go to mattdelia.com uh and that is great
for that and all of the new Lifeline
merch is at lifelinemirch.com you guys
we're ripping also ready for Black
Friday too uh I'm sorry Black Friday but
the holiday seasons
um you can get uh Lifeline merch for
your your loved ones or whatever the
[ __ ] you want there and uh it's good it
makes good for holiday gift giving
um holiday gift giving sounds foreign
you get merch for your loved ones
Lifeline merch for your loved ones
for the holidays or you hate us okay you
want us all to turn a lot in between
that's like saying skate or die you know
I never liked that because you also
there's a lot you can do I'm just
letting them know if they don't get
their loved ones merch our merch they
[ __ ] hate us okay so what about the
fact that maybe they don't they don't
even think about it or they don't even
watch the podcast to hate us okay well
that's very that's a hard line they're
doing us dirty they should be fans they
should watch and then if they don't they
hate us and now here's the thing though
if you do watch and you do get Lifeline
merch for your for your loved ones
friends and family whatever
you love us and even better we love you
back oh wow that's cool yeah so it's
very transactional our love yeah yeah
yeah completely yeah yeah okay well
that's okay you know I don't I don't
know what do you think about like being
in a relationship like uh where where
where okay so there's what do you think
about being in a relationship where it's
about money what do you mean Define I
was actually thinking about this the
other day uh what do you think about
like
I mean you know take Tony Soprano and
[ __ ] obviously he's doing horrible [ __ ]
but like you know he would like talk to
Edie Falco and be like hey I got your
[ __ ] car you know yeah and she'd be
like oh thank you Tony and it was all
brushed under the rug right now
obviously people aren't out there being
Hitman I mean there are but like being
in a relationship
yeah no I know but I'm saying there's
not really mob bosses anymore okay well
there are kind of Hitmen okay I don't
know well I know you know what I mean I
don't do it but I've seen a lot of
National Geographic stuff about the
underbelly of okay yeah uh and so what
do you think about being in a
relationship where it's like hey got you
this you know what I mean and the
woman's like okay well that's not really
my dream relationship but I'm I'm a
hooker a bit a little well that sounds
[ __ ] terrible the way you're
describing it sounds terrible she's
laughing seems like she's insecure
laughing like she's unhealthy and then
she says I'm a horror okay well she
doesn't say I'm a [ __ ] but that's like
the you know
the subtext of it it's like okay well I
think then yes I think that is bad you
think it's bad okay but what if they're
both happy and they die kind of like
together and they have a great family
and stuff as long as they're not mob
bosses or hit men or doing anything else
violent in the world then everybody
should do exactly what they want yeah
okay I guess I'm just thinking about
like you know some people do marry for
money and do you think that's bad I
guess that's what I'm asking
yeah marrying for money and and uh
uh security like in that way you think
that's bad no I don't think that's bad I
think that people are attracted to
security and they're I think you see it
less when men marry for like money and
security and things like that but I
think that happens too I think the
typical one is like Women Marry rich men
gold digging ass yeah well sounds like
you got some stuff no I don't but I'm
saying relationship but but gold digging
ass [ __ ] gold digging that [ __ ] you're
driving me crazy I can take it no more
fellas kick it did he not say fellas
sing it I don't know go digging girls
driving me crazy I can't take it no more
fellas sing it girl and then they go go
yeah cause then they would sing it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
was that 90s uh that was early 90s yeah
well a rap song that says fellow sing is
unbelievable oh it does say sing it
it doesn't even say it he just says Sing
mc nasd mc nasty oh nasty is that what
it was yeah wow dude
it's my Cadillac wow that's the name of
the oh God I don't remember that at all
though yeah well you just had the single
I think it was a DJ what's this what's
that say DJ it's Mick
wow now we're talking I mean that would
still be in a movie where they don't
[ __ ] right right they don't know [ __ ]
about shopping and we'll call them DJ
Freaky Fred yeah yeah
look look at the lyrics Me and my homie
took the van and we drove it to the
store so basic a Paul Simon song there
was there was a female there that we had
never seen before wow this is a Paul
song will be like me and my homie took a
van and we drove into the Zone it was a
female that we had never seen before
basically Simon and Garfunkel her body
looked looked nice her body looked nice
her hair was in a curl but from the
looks of things we could tell she's a
material girl she had lots of gold rings
fingers that were stacked my homie
looked at me and said nasty let's Jack I
almost took the bait but I just couldn't
do it always running late so I had to
get to it okay well that's pretty much
enough but where's the good part but
what I want to know is why didn't you
let me do my Paul Simon thing with it
because you kind of stopped me short
there I didn't like I didn't like it
that much why it was the number one why
I want to know why why didn't I like it
it is it is funny and it is
um Paul Simon ish you know he would just
kind of talk [ __ ] yeah I thought
honestly here's a here's what oh boy I
just I thought what you did was enough
already I think you didn't need to do
anymore it wasn't you know me I could
keep going and make it you could yeah
but I'm saying I didn't want that so I
kept going with what I was saying
because I had had it was just the right
amount it was good but there was no more
to it so I let there there was more to
it yeah you want to know why I'll tell
you why because I didn't get to the
funny [ __ ] words that would be funny
if Paul Simon said it right like looked
did that would have been funny if Paul
Simon did it like let's do it like go go
so I can scroll with me no no no no what
the heck is going on me and Mommy took
the van and we drove it to the store and
there was a female that we had never
seen before but it looked at nice her
hair was in a curable from the looks of
things look at those she has a material
girl lots of gold rings fingers that
were stacked my homie looked at me and
says nasty let's Jack that's a little
funnier because Paul Simon saying nasty
let's Jack okay also was he talking
about masturbating he doesn't finish
Jack looked at I mean I know it means
steel dude you're gonna steal the girl
let's Jack
just steal the girl
her rings dude wow dude you that's so
[ __ ] hardcore gangster to steal from
a woman like that deal Jewelry off of a
woman in public yeah also he the song's
gold digging girls and he's talking
about robbing women with rings
girls driving me crazy I can't take it
no more fella singing better because
Matt's tone deaf fellas sing it better
than me
digging girls wanna be crazy I can't
take it no more dude they should remake
this this song would if they remade this
[ __ ] that would kill right now I'm
telling you how would it go what would
you kind of how I did it right there oh
just the way you did she contact you and
see nasty and freaky Friday Friday or
whatever his name is she should contact
you yeah they should dude I mean they
probably died honestly of like diabetes
or something but anyway wow
um how much would that guy one of them
died yeah for sure I got one time I saw
a [ __ ] dude a 48. remember remember
the the show Starsky and Hutch Yeah well
yeah I S one time I I said dude how much
did one of those guys die from HIV and
and then I looked it up and he did what
yep dude that's how good I am one of
Starsky and Hutch died of [ __ ] I believe
so unless I'm completely wrong and
daydream that whole thing on the way
over here how sad is that well it's very
sad look it up and see if uh the guy
died of HIV from starskin that's a good
way to [ __ ] kick things off oh yeah
hey guys welcome to Lifeline the guy
from Sergeant hust died of agent not not
the movie not the movie obviously not
the movie
well just to go
he died of HIV
no just say just type in aids with it
got it not at Google man hey did you
know no it's all right I like this way
yeah we don't know how to Google see now
he was he committed to this way he
should have just kept going because
there's one more guy to click on and
it's probably that guy but we don't know
yet how crazy is that got to throw a
blood transfer but we know how he really
got it right no dude that was super
super common really yeah it's actually
one of the most devastating Parts what
nobody really talks about that's how
Arthur Ashe got it oh really yeah I
thought it was gay no no oh wow gonna
get canceled again it's all good but
yeah no that's that's uh
that's I did think our others was gay
though no well he might I mean I
actually had no idea but he got it from
a blood transfusion oh wow all right
well uh this is a very uplifting episode
the book and the band played on you know
yeah it gets into all that [ __ ] that's
about Arthur Ashe no it gets into how
many people got blood trans it like
writes it as it developed in real time
it's the most incredible world it's
actually
the most upsetting book I've ever read
isn't that and the BAM isn't about like
War people from war no no it's an
expression that the gay community and
not
yeah I see but it's a book first right
right but but Matthew redeem was in a
movie and then they wrote the book on it
right
the book about Matthew Modine movie and
then Matthew Modine contracted HIV all
right uh let's go to uh one of the
things how would you say that look at
that so you look good your hair looks
good man your hair looks good like that
too dude it's like a little [ __ ]
shitty Little Pony no it's fine it's not
it's not a shitty book it's not
premature the people with the premature
Ponies are [ __ ] awful the guys so
badly you know yeah that's what that is
yeah all right let's go to a thing to
try to make me look worse than him on TV
they're great man you look great uh
let's go to the light let's go to some
some some fan videos or some listener
videos
I'm kicking I'm all right oh I'm kind of
all right they deviated my septum and
broke my nose really bad so I can't
breathe in the one side gotta get served
pause it here so this guy was the guy
that got burned no fool first you got
burned then then he got uh jacked and
beat up on his birthday right and and
then he had like a burrito of some kind
right the really crazy awesome
girlfriend broke up with him right but
on his birthday and he got and he got
beat up but great ending to the story is
that he got a burrito from buckaroos or
whatever the [ __ ] it was you know yeah
what was that place called got [ __ ]
burned alive beat the [ __ ] out of
girlfriend broke up with me and also for
the final installment got a burrito from
buckaroos what is it what's it called
bubbakuz oh you were so close I was
close well buckaroos I feel like he's a
thing Bubba because it's not but
bubbaku's is now a store so okay anyway
okay that's so the shirt he would wear
tooth too don't really got money for too
much of that stuff but [ __ ] it life
still rips I'm winging it Chris I
remember you said that you didn't see
any scars on my arm I wore a short
sleeve shirt so you can kind of see it
this time but the camera really doesn't
do it justice but I did all I healed
really well I got super lucky with the
healing but the camera doesn't do the
burns Justice at all in real life you
could easily tell where the old skin
hits the new skin where I'm all scarred
up and how the old inside of my arm is
pink ah whatever man Matt dude as soon
as I get some money I'm gonna pay for
one of those phone calls and hop on with
you explain the full story because now I
got to explain the full story of this
past two months to you guys somehow dude
I don't know how but I like I said I'm
broke right now but as soon as I have
money I'm gonna try to thank you guys so
much for making me laugh about
everything dude it was [ __ ] hilarious
you really had me cracking up you guys
you're [ __ ] awesome dude thank you so
much you're the man dude I'm gonna pay
for his session with you let him know I
want to pay for his session with Matt
because we want to we want to hear about
it okay okay all right let him know
um that that guy is uh what a [ __ ] a
guy's like this dude I admire guys like
this so much when you say guys like this
people who are positive oh yeah like
this guy been through some [ __ ] and he's
just this is the embodiment of Life rips
this is what I [ __ ] love he literally
got burned yeah almost burned alive his
his girlfriend broke up with him he got
jacked and beat up by 15 guys yeah and
then it's like there's one more thing
yeah the dude's like yeah but check out
this beautiful burrito yeah like this
guy I mean talk about the upswing of the
burrito going back to the first few
things right but this guy just this guy
is the guy that you figured life out bro
if people were like you if you were
happy like you you know how great the
world would be dude this guy looks at
the thing he doesn't look at it half
half full he looks at it totally full
even if it's only half full yeah this is
a beautiful man and I love this dude but
at a certain point you're just
inaccurate you know if you're yeah I
know if it's actually half full and
you're like that's full then you're just
crazy but the guy seems yeah I
understand but the guy seems like he's
just got a great outlook on life and
this is great we started the [ __ ]
episode with that especially since we
were talking about HIV and people dying
the way you said that I did yeah okay
well zoomed through and it all sounded
all muddled and meshed together zoom
zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom
remember that that one's better yeah
yeah
it's like from Only the Strong or some
[ __ ] you're gonna get is that the one
that says do you wanna Maestro
that'll never know actually being
interviews over I I talked about that in
congratulations my other hit podcast on
this channel super cold subscribe and uh
they said uh and people sent it to me
and the job interview is over guys but
what is it from do we have I think it's
from Only the Strong oh okay Joe being
Derby is over no job interview is not
over yet to have interviews and not over
jet yeah that's what it was so foreign
just say it in your language at some
point at a certain point just be like
just add one second adding so many J's
yeah and B's yeah that don't go there um
so this guy dude congratulations to this
guy this guy figured out life at a young
age life rips that's the embodiment of
Life rips and we [ __ ] love you here
at Lifeline dude and I'm gonna pay for
your session for Matt
all right sounds like a success
Matt and Chris hello my name is Barbara
Ann huge fan love you guys so much
um I am a single mom got a beautiful
seven-year-old daughter cute I'm looking
to buy a house and my mom also is going
to be moving from where she is but
cannot afford
to live where we live in the area that
we live currently by herself so
I have put it out there that you know
there's a lot more Pros to the scenario
in which we buy a house together with
some privacy of course she can she can
be in the basement
um but I I'm a little hesitant because I
feel like I'm going to lose my
Independence somewhat and the dating
life is non-existent right now to my own
my by my own choice but what if things
change I guess my question is do you see
it as a red flag or a turn off
dating someone with their mommy in the
basement
um and I don't want to make this too
long but Chris thank you for the picture
in DC I was the creep waiting outside
for you oh yeah someone get VIP tickets
you're the best
um got me through some tough times in
2018 where I wasn't smiling as much or
laughing as much so you and the movie
trolls if you haven't watched it with
Calvin I recommend it
thank you thank you
um Matt if you're ever in Northern
Virginia let's uh meet up and see what
happens thank you guys
um I gotta say that I I remember her she
was very sweet and um uh yeah you know
what I I don't know man it's not a red
flag to me you know people not at all
it's a circumstance that yeah here's
when it is a red flag is when you are
like
when you're [ __ ] when you're
that when you're there because
you can you can't afford to live
somewhere else oh when you're living
with your parents or parent right one of
them and it's because like you don't
make money and they are putting you
under their roof that can be a red flag
that can be a record but you housing
your parent no not a red flag because
you have enough money and they don't
it's not even a little bit that actually
is like really admirable yeah now of
course you're gonna run into privacy
issues that that's for the that's a
given right but uh remember and Martha
and Grandpa yeah that was awesome we've
seen a situation up close like that and
it's the Privacy was never invaded from
what I know I don't even remember
sometimes where I was like where's there
a month I want to go see Aunt Martha you
gotta go down and knock and everything
in the house bro that was like a dream
yeah weird I'd love to see that house
again yeah it was crazy wow but they
worked out for them yeah we had a
grandpa we we have our my father's
parents had who's who was it that was
that was Bam's uh sister was it yeah
okay yeah uh my grandpa Bam's sister
um lived downstairs in the basement it
was like a whole separate house
basically yeah uh and it was it was
great yeah and you know I don't know if
you're it also depends like how old your
mom you know if you only got like 10
years left it's kind of a nice thing I
think I think it's kind of [ __ ] sick
in general just like
I don't know if especially if you get
along with your mom I would do it I mean
I I have actually thought about this I
would I would actually do that too I
would let my mom live with me as long as
again as long as there was a situation
where we could be separate yeah yeah I
would do that um
is weird to say because 20 or 10 years
ago was no [ __ ] way 10 years ago you
were [ __ ] 28 it's way different yeah
you know and uh yeah yeah I would do it
too yeah I don't think it's a red flag
and I think that it's it's a beautiful
thing and I think that you know any guy
that's gonna think that that's shitty
didn't want to [ __ ] be with dude yeah
that's true actually it's a good way to
weed out [ __ ] losers I actually you
know I thought you had a guy and uh then
that might raise an issue if if you know
I understand the spouse or something
being like I don't know if I want my
mother-in-law here but even I would I
would do that too yeah I I love my
mother-in-law but you know
yeah I love your mother-in-law too she's
great right amorsley isn't she what look
I'm in love with her oh wow is the first
place in time I've ever said it oh wow
that seems bad probably I'm in love with
your mother did you tell me that
privately or not at all anyway go ahead
okay let's do another one now a word
from our sponsor better help
therapy is a lifesaver it is the
greatest life solution that one can give
oneself I cannot recommend it any higher
uh life simply does not come with a user
manual but therapy and therapists
therapists
can really really help
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
plus it's actually affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
the therapist if things are not clicking
with that therapist you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
could not be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist it's all done by them
learn more and save 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
Lifeline that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash Lifeline holidays are
here the holidays are here it is the
season of giving people things we are
popping our merch all over the place
thank you thanks to ship station ship
station is the bomb as my mom says the
most wonderful time of the year is also
the most hectic Time of the Year
everyone puts off shopping until the
last minute I know I do and if you have
an online store you know the feeling of
getting hit with a ton of orders all at
once when you're buried in orders and
emails from stress customers you will
wish you had ship station ship station
turns holidays ship storms into smooth
sailings so you can keep your customers
happy and still find time to enjoy some
eggnog
shipstation Keeps Us prepared for
Lifeline drops and the holiday season
for our merch everybody loves ship
station over 130 000 companies have
grown their e-commerce businesses with
ship station and 98 of companies that
stick with ship station for a year
become customers for life baby faux life
this holiday season give yourself the
gift of stress-free holiday shipping use
the promo code Lifeline today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com
promo code lifeline
here we go oh he's so warm oh that's a
prison Matt he's so warm oh yeah he's
one of his [ __ ] or or freezing and can't
get a hold of or maybe he has HIV you
know what I mean do you recognize this
guy what what you acted like you might
recognize this guy no no because he was
gonna play a woman that was beautiful
and then instead played this guy and it
was a stark difference I mean there was
like a beautiful redhead with piercing
blue eyes and then this guy came no
offense of the dude but like he's got a
good thing going on yeah he's got his
own thing going on right he's also got a
great hoodie yeah it says life for
episode 100 in Houston Texas love the
show guys uh Chris if you remember I uh
called in on the golden hour the first
episode about uh what do you do if
someone parks in your parking spot I
kind of wanted to get Mass advice on
this also just to see what he has to say
and uh just as a
I guess a further bit of information the
the parking garage is gated in they
parked in my spot inside of a gated
garage it wasn't like it was just one of
those apartment complex parking spots
all over the place so
you know it's a little different but uh
yeah I had someone parking my spot on
Halloween
inside the garage and I ended up having
their car towed
so Chris already know what you think
yeah what do you think about it thanks
guys
why don't you before I tell you what
everyone said on Golden hour why don't
you [ __ ] go ahead and chime in I mean
yeah [ __ ] tell that [ __ ] get
his ass out of there it's not his
[ __ ] spot bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye-bye so you don't have to be shitty
about it but you know I Eric was saying
tell that [ __ ] tow that
[ __ ] Brendan was saying I get it
it's Halloween really hard to find
parking what are you supposed to do
though we're gonna ruin the guy's day
who cares he he should have read the
final I was kind of in the middle I said
I understand why you would tow it and I
might tow it as well
but but then Brenda was like What if
he's with his kids and then you ruined
the guy's day which I was shocked that
Brennan said that but yeah man uh dude
if he's with his kids he certainly
shouldn't I said in a better [ __ ]
example I know I know I get it I I think
I lean towards what you what you're
saying yeah also the did that was that
detail known that it was in a private
[ __ ] we did not know it was in a gate
that's a big [ __ ] deal yeah yeah then
you never do that I agree I agree you
shouldn't the guy should know not to do
it and now he knows forever
because he got [ __ ] towed so do the
kids dude so do the kids now everyone
knows and that's a good lesson to learn
so not only did he do the right thing he
taught the whole family a lesson a very
valuable lesson yeah right he's you know
he is a real hero we talk about dream
Heroes but he's a real hero yeah he's a
hero all right cool yeah I I agree I
agree I think I was maybe swayed because
when Brenda was saying I was feeling bad
for the kids and it was Halloween and
[ __ ] like that but yeah but even still
where's the [ __ ] Park I'm not
impressionable dude I'm very very very
hard in my stance oh okay okay but I'm a
real man the real question at the end of
everything is where was the guy supposed
to park if he has nowhere to park he has
to tell them that guy was supposed to
yeah yeah
I I understand
um I think Brennan's thing was it was
Halloween it's really hard to park
because everything he was saying that
everything was crowded because it was
Halloween stay home [ __ ] well
he's got kids he can't stay home he's
got a trigger send them out yeah I get
it okay send them out I get it dude I
don't even really disagree with you and
you're talking to me like I like I'm
disagreeing with you and that's honestly
I don't like that it's on me okay that's
whatever well I feel very strongly about
this
okay I would I would tow the
[ __ ] Okay hard wow and I would
stand in like this oh you'd watch
as it happened
and then what if the guy says
[ __ ] my kids and his kids are
all dressed up like clowns and [ __ ] like
sad I go like this
you have no heart
so you move the microphone to your face
and then back it away again okay all
right well [ __ ] man yeah no you're hard
you're hardcore especially when it comes
to holidays and party for those only
listening what I was doing is I was
folding my arms in front of my chest but
high like where my nipples are right
like a like a [ __ ] like a school
teacher yeah like waiting for the class
to be or like a really fat guy with
short arms uh oh okay or that yeah
um all right so all right yeah that you
know let's do the next one I feel like
that's uh I feel like that ain't that
ain't that ain't bad
hey Chris and Matt love you guys love
the podcast I'll get right into it
um what advice would you have for
somebody who's afraid of the spotlight
and success specifically someone whose
career literally involves like being in
the spotlight
I'm a singer-songwriter love music I
know it's what I meant to do and I have
no doubts about that
um I just know that being in the
spotlight is going to be like one of my
biggest hurdles to get over
um I also struggle to believe in myself
and so I need a lot of Praise positive
constant feedback in order to feel
confident about like anything I'm doing
or putting out there and I'm afraid that
the more I put myself out there and
receive that kind of Praise that I'm
just going to become dependent on it and
my confidence is going to remain
dependent on what other people think of
me so Chris I know you've talked about
this a little bit being a performer
yourself and Matt you give really solid
advice so I'm curious what y'all will
have to say but thank you so much very
smart self-aware person uh I started I
think that here's the deal
give your social media over to someone
to do it do not check social media find
your self-worth and your praise from
your family and your friends you're very
you're very emotionally you can you know
we can tell in this [ __ ] minute long
video that emotionally you're a smart
person uh we know that obviously you
because you say this that you suffer
from uh you know I I don't want to say
being insecure but but you rely on other
people to make you feel good look use it
in your music use it in your music and
and this is why you do what you do and
also thank God you're not a comedian
because you literally have to depend on
people laughing as a musician in the
spotlight those lights are bright I
don't know how much you perform but
those are bright you can't see people
dude zone out you're not even there dude
you're in your [ __ ] living room just
doing it and they're there to see that
they're there to see you doing that in
your living room so just Zone the [ __ ]
out you're in the spotlight in in the
physical form but in your head you're in
your living room and shut down the
social media have social have someone
else do the social media the way you're
talking right now and you're going to
become dependent on the social media
you're going to see the hate you're
going to see the [ __ ] that people say
that's not good it's just toxic man
social media [ __ ] with you trust me
take it from me get death threats all
the time yes so it's like you gotta
[ __ ] just shut down the social media
aspect of it and zone out and just focus
on the music especially when you're
performing in front of people focus on
the music dude yeah
um I think also shh do it more as much
as you can the only thing to combat that
kind of fear is to face it over and over
and over again until it becomes less and
less of a fear yeah I know when you were
starting out doing comedy it was the
same thing you would go up at hostels
without a microphone yeah [ __ ] diners
like an open mic night and I was always
like what the [ __ ] are you doing crazy
that sounds miserable and not even
similar to what uh doing a stand-up set
is like and it was just for you it was
just like the more you did it the less
afraid you got about doing it and and
the more you got used to doing it and
that's creates this positive cycle of
like you you need less and less yeah
feedback all the time that you're doing
it well because you're used to it now
and you get this you get the [ __ ]
hang of it and [ __ ] you know I feel like
I don't know but it sounds like she
doesn't go up that often to perform in
front of people it's different as a
singer exactly so you gotta just what
I'm saying is any gig you can get even
if it's at a senior citizen home right
you get in [ __ ] front of them and you
just do it because it's at the end of
the day it's all the same there's people
who want to hear you play music yeah uh
it's it's a thing you can get over for
sure so that's that's good right it's
not like something you can't get over uh
you might always have a little bit of it
but like man I did I used to go up
in hostels in rooms in hostels where
people who didn't speak English were
waiting for a comedy show I and they
were like oh there's a comedy show here
okay we were going to go drink but we
will watch this for 20 minutes yeah and
and I I would go up there would be no
stage I just walk from the back of the
room to the front of the room and I
would be like hey guys
what's the deal with [ __ ] you know
Apple computers and sometimes they would
laugh and sometimes I would just be in a
room and just talking and they would not
be laughing but I get over that [ __ ]
that sounds just so so strange but I
loved it dude I loved it and I wouldn't
change it for anything because I did it
and it was strange and I would and I
would bomb but dude it got me so good at
at just talking and and zoning out as I
say uh you need to be connected with the
crowd but zoning out it's like when I do
my podcast dude I'm having a blast I'm
killing nobody's in the room but I feel
like I'm killing and I think it's funny
and I don't need now I don't need people
to laugh like dude that's what I'm
saying the more you yeah but this
podcast like I say [ __ ] at in this
podcast that I say in other podcasts
that everybody would be people would be
laughing but you're my brother and
you're used to this [ __ ] and you don't
laugh that's true sometimes but I know
it's funny and I do it anyway I've
thought about that actually yeah yeah
and I know you think it's funny but
you're just not laughing or you don't
think it's funny and I don't give a [ __ ]
well I mean I've been seeing the same
jokes for like 38. you didn't see the
Paul Simon one but you know and it's
fine but like the Paul Simon one was
funny you didn't laugh at it and I know
it's funny deep down I know it's I know
how funny it is and you're like I didn't
like it that much but I liked it just I
thought the allocated amount of time
that I gave it was the right amount of
time okay yeah yeah we could revisit it
at some point and honestly we probably
will in a way in our lives at some point
anyway because of how I reuse jokes all
the time right right yeah I read you I
use jokes all the time like here's one I
reuse all the time okay somebody says
have you ever had anal sex and I say
yeah you know it's okay but it makes my
my butt hurt right right yeah I love
that joke okay and and one time I made
the direct a director uh cry laughing
with it and I always think about it
really and and that's the hardest that
that joke ever hit congratulations man
just feeling good yeah okay so
all right and you didn't laugh at it and
I still know what's funny I didn't laugh
at it yeah and if I said it at the
hospital I bet those [ __ ] Germans
would die at that right yeah because
he's doing so I thought he was okay
right right right yeah yeah
I mean [ __ ] I have a question for Chris
how do I use a napkin
um where's my mouth how did you become
so sick with it well I mean
oh wow you know just so that was the
best submission we ever gotten and
because of the chocolate on his face it
was so quick you know what was good
about his it sounded like Chris cut his
ass off because it went too long right
like that wasn't the end of his video
that was the end of this oh really oh
dude
how to get too sick with it
Let's Play It Again look at his slovenly
I have a question for Chris Chris
um
how did you become so sick with it
thanks oh even better
first take us for our time first off he
started wiping his face when he had [ __ ]
all over it what do you mean that's how
you started oh that's how I started me
it's like step one or step one when you
when it looks like you have dookie on
your mouth yeah yeah yeah wow dude so
that's number one yeah I mean dude
didn't give it that guy doesn't give a
[ __ ] honestly how sexy is that guy in a
relationship for real because he so
doesn't give a [ __ ] I mean zero percent
sexy okay if anyone was going in to kiss
that guy no when he had this [ __ ] on his
face but the attitude about it is that
he did the video and thought and
obviously saw he's not blind because
he's driving he wanted it like he
thought it was funny that's why I don't
know okay then never mind you know he
thought it was being funny all right
okay but he still has his question he's
pretty sick with it already you think so
I mean you he's asking you I mean I
probably don't want to hang out with a
guy like that but he's pretty sick with
it okay because he's already he doesn't
give a [ __ ] that's what makes you say
these two things that he's already sick
with it eh and that you wouldn't want to
hang out with him well because I don't
want to hang out with a guy who thinks
it's good to have [ __ ] stuff all over
his face that's disgusting to me okay
period for any amount of time yes and
then uh he's already sick with it
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] what
people think obviously okay because now
he's on you know hundreds of millions of
people are going to see this yes
billions yes by the way subscribe to the
channel we need to bring break 596 this
is a conspiracy super cold sooner or
later even I who never believed
anything's a conspiracy will start to
think this is yeah neither do I do it
but I'm starting to be like okay man
maybe we're a little bit Alex Jones in
this [ __ ] all right let's go here we go
next one
hey Chris um hey Matt I love both of you
tons Chris I'm a true baby Matt I love
the perspective that you have to offer
on literally everything
um my name is Jenny I'm 23 years old I'm
from Sacramento California
um my question is I guess I need advice
on
how do you get over
someone who you really like and who
really likes you
but at the end of the day
um you're just not compatible in the
things that you want at a relationship
and the direction you want to go in life
do you think that you can still maintain
a friendship with that person
or that at the end of the day it's just
gonna be messy and uh end in heartache
because that's what I feel is gonna
happen
um but I also don't want to close off a
really good friendship so what do you
guys think can you get over somebody
while still being their friend
thank you have a good day guys I love
you and I appreciate you Calvin's the
cutest Matt marinade Okay bye so what's
up with she yeah she would obviously
want to marry me too but I'm already
married but uh that's fine
that's like two videos now where the
women were just like Matt I love you I
want to have your children but they're
basically I know and they're doing that
to play hard to get for me
um
uh
yeah I what it why do you want so okay
you guys are such good friends you guys
are
you guys tried the horizontal Mambo and
apparently it went nice right but the
thing is they're not compatible meaning
they want different things in life
so I think why don't you just keep
trying dude keep trying what break him
make him do what you want do what women
do all the time historically throughout
the ages deeper change him
break him make him come over to your
area and have kids or whatever you want
that he doesn't want break him nah I
don't I don't agree with that at all I
agree I agree with myself because then
there's going to be resentment coming
from what there is any way in a
relationship no matter what no get out
of here break him yeah you get out of
here with the deeper [ __ ] dude no I
reject all of what you're saying okay I
don't reject it okay well that's because
you said it I agree with me so
if you guys are it sounds like you've
already decided that it's not com we're
going to work out between you
romantically which is probably
absolutely right break okay so that's
out of the way that's not even what she
was asking about Chris break them so
what you should do from that point on is
if you're worried about being friends
you think it's going to end in heartache
you think it's going to end badly for
this or that reason you are very likely
to be right about that break them stop
saying that okay and you are very likely
to
being for a world a world of hurt a
world of hurt where one woman tries to
be friends with somebody else that she
should have broken but didn't yeah one
world one heart
a Broken Man starring Vin Diesel wow I
mean I would see that yeah oh yeah that
would be his like time to go try for an
oscar but he did that remember with
Sydney the mat no what he did uh your
honor or something about uh
I plea well it's such a bad title what
was it
the the Vin Diesel movie that he played
a lawyer with with for Cindy lamette
what's the Vin Diesel Sydney lamette
movie yeah
it's like a thing find me guilty find me
guilty wow beanie boom
what's that song I don't
know I don't know why you're doing it
though oh
that song you know it it sounds sick
what's up what is that song
Anthony
I'm pissed
how about this dude how about such a
crazy guy
what's the hip-hop song with bed squeaks
in it
oh is it true that's what it seems
that's what it seems you know
I mean
just just a fully sound effect here we
go
yeah
you were doing it pretty good
after 30 seconds though that's so so
annoying no
the squeaking
get to it guys you know it's been a
minute all right well it's over now
that's right
um
took a while for me to find the note all
right
okay that's very cool okay uh so now
about this woman yeah I think you since
you've already decided it's not going to
work out as a relationship trust that
and also trust your instinct that it's
not going to work out as friends break
them you can be friends
with an X it's just like don't expect it
you know you got to work hard at that
[ __ ] and then but working hard at it
presumes you really want it to work out
as a friendship and I don't know why
people always insist oh but we should
still stay friends why based on what is
that maybe they were friends yeah that
that I guess makes sense but you're
gonna have that moment where you guys
are like yeah like all right coach so
you want to help me move friend and he's
like yeah okay cool and they're gonna
move the couch and be like oh that's
great yeah okay it's cool yeah wow okay
okay so anyway well I'm gonna go uh oh
sorry oh I didn't mean to oh I didn't
need to okay yeah it's all
[Music]
that is the most disgusting thing I've
ever seen in my life when you go up and
like lick her face whatever that is it's
tongue kissing that's what it would look
like without the face if you yeah it's
just so disgusting
that's him
okay she's she's eating his butt okay so
uh what's up trust your instincts you're
you're right about them all of them you
bro you broke me didn't you
you should be laughing but it doesn't
matter though because I am a true
comedian and I've done hostels with no
microphones wow to people who don't
speak English wow so I hear the laughs
no matter what wow crazy guy here's
people laughing when they're not there
dude
the way
dude you laughed you laughed I laughed
at that one yeah you laughed at that
that's great [ __ ] yeah dude yeah okay
all right let's do another one okay now
that I've great advice sufficient
where are we actually press play
let's just take 97 of Stanley Kubrick to
record this and make it perfect
I have a big hand talker and it's
obnoxious and I say um a lot so anyway
uh the other day I was talking to my mom
about how I can't breathe fast forward
so because I'm no she's like I'm a
listener congratulations a lifeline and
I'm obviously a part of the super cult
baby
I thought I had a deviated subject just
because of the way that it sounded what
you went through
um obviously talking to Chris sorry Matt
I have it too [ __ ] we love you
too so anyway
go to ear nose and throat today and it
turns out I have a severe deviated
septum it goes so far over that it
almost completely cuts off my right
Airway so I obviously need the surgery
but I don't know what to expect I feel
really anxious I don't know how painful
it's going to be the recovery time and
the doctor really sketches me out oh
well that's so please just let me know
how to handle the anxiety and just what
to expect
um thank you so much I'm a big fan bye
alprazy baby Alprazolam
which is Xanax
for Xanax
you're recommending Xanax no I'm not I'm
kidding okay well I mean it helps but I
think that uh yeah look you're gonna
have anxiety you know why and it's okay
because they're doing surgery in your
head in the center of your head focus on
shouldn't we focus on her the doctor
sketches are out well yeah the other
doctor yeah well definitely get a second
opinion if the doctor doctor does catch
you up but I have a feeling she's just
kind of saying [ __ ] just judging on how
she's saying stuff okay so don't think
the person who called in she's just this
woman who just asked for Our advice is
exaggerating or making I feel like she's
no I don't think she's making stuff up I
think she's just kind of trying to be
cute and funny with that specifically
that's what my first instinct was okay
and I read people yeah okay right so um
but I think that you you know go get a
second opinion anyway yeah right but
yeah if you have a deviated septum get
the x-rays and then [ __ ] like that you
have it right I have a really bad idea I
had it they fixed it and it's great how
is it now everything's great yeah wow
dude I asked Kristen the other day I was
like how much less do I snore and she
said if you snort a hundred percent
you're at five percent or ten percent oh
well that's crazy I don't even snore I
just I have it during the day you don't
no I don't know at all yeah you know who
snores a lot David Sullivan I took him
on the road the past few times oh yeah
and bro the guy snores and I thought
someone was cutting down a tree dude and
um do it so she it's like dude I can't
even it's like oh dude yeah all right
yeah yeah like the Hawking sounds stupid
it's so disgusting and he's got a big
head and he's fat so he's got a huge
head but you know what else dude he's
really fast a nice fat he's old yeah and
so oh yeah it's definitely any short so
I think that
I think that uh
I think that
um you gotta go so it's very it's a very
you know what it is it's a very invasive
surgery because it gets in the center of
your head and you don't think about how
it's an invasive surgery because you're
like they're fixing a little thing in my
nose but it affects a lot the first
night absolutely sucks there's no
there's no two ways about it it just
sucks pain meds pain meds pain meds but
it doesn't suck because it hurts
absolutely pain meds it doesn't hurt
because it suck because it hurts it
sucks the pain meds I understand but
it's I didn't even take payments okay
well there's a big mistake but go ahead
but you know me dude what's that I'm
[ __ ] very like my pain talk it's
crazy bro I'm like really a man
really a man yeah so but the the the
tampons that they put up your nose the
worst are the worst have you had that
right yeah remember my members came out
and I didn't know it was even up there
yep one night I just felt this thing
coming out of my [ __ ] face
[ __ ] face and dude there's a [ __ ]
big like mound of cotton stuck in my
face no you didn't know that that was in
there they didn't tell me that's weird
and then so and then when did you take
it out the day after no no when did it
come out oh like a week so you had that
up there for a week yeah on both sides
so they only make you keep it up there
for uh um a day now
oh
very uneventful the way why why I don't
know but so they put what happens up
there it's a day and then they have the
stints up there for a week but the
stints are not so bad they're they're
pretty awful but the tampons are you
can't breathe out of your nose yeah
um but yeah definitely get it done dude
definitely get it done it's worth it I I
definitely am going I knew a guy that
got it done
uh and then I had to get it done again
and I I will tell you this much I don't
know if I would do it again that's how
[ __ ] annoying yeah I like if I got
hit in the nose five years down the line
maybe I would forget about how annoying
it was but like
I don't know man it [ __ ] sucks that
recovery it just sucks man wow the fact
that you don't know if you do it again
is wild but I'm glad but I but I am glad
I did it well yeah now but doing it
twice I don't know man wow like it took
three months for it to [ __ ] actually
feel like all better and that's pretty
good right doesn't it usually yeah
sometimes it takes like half a year yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well so yeah get that [ __ ] yeah I think
you should get it though get a second
opinion
but a deviated septum is real real easy
to tell if you have it it's not like
yeah you need a second opinion but if
you hit your doctor
definitely do that I think honestly uh I
you know it's cool that she figured it
out for my podcast and I didn't realize
that I saved lives
yeah you save lives people have said
that before well yes making it real I
was joking but making it real no but I'm
being serious dude there was a woman
that came up to me the other day that
said that my podcast helped her get
through
um by the way a lot of people [ __ ]
love this podcast man yeah yeah like
they come up to me at the meet and
greets and they're like yeah my fine uh
they say like we love Matt tell Matt
yeah you know yeah you don't tell me
enough yeah no I don't actually but uh
um yeah what was I saying oh yeah
somebody came up to me and they said
that they that they had a preemie babies
like twins and that they would listen to
congratulations during that time and
they were in and out of the hospital and
it was [ __ ] horrible and she like
just broke down in front of my God and
had me sign her uh Hospital bracelet
baby oh really yeah yeah it was really
really like it was and our babies are
great now like show me pictures how long
ago like what like it was like a year
ago that they were born wow yeah and
they're just two beautiful twins now two
beautiful babies now right that's fine
and what they are though and and it's so
and it really was touching man it really
touched me and like and I was so happy
to see the babies healthy and like the
fact that they wanted me to sign their
bracelets like their Hospital bracelets
was like it was just such an honor man
and and you know I don't know if I don't
know their names but I I remember their
faces and they were just really [ __ ]
sweet and and and that stuff is so you
know I know we were obviously getting
off on a real note here but but um it
was just really beautiful man and I'm so
fortunate you know we really are
fortunate that we [ __ ] that we have
these people that listen to this podcast
and like enjoy this like mm-hmm you ever
feel that yeah I do also when you said
the Vince Vaughn thing it made me think
of oh the [ __ ] Vince Vaughn due to
that story yeah okay this is after
Wedding Crashers by the way right yes
okay yes yes so we were trying to this
is almost 20 actually almost 20 years
ago yeah we were trying to make a movie
who wrote it me or you who wrote it uh
you you wrote it I wrote it you wrote it
I wrote the script it was called selling
desks and I was gonna direct it
and uh we were we had this producer
attached who was much older than us who
many years later it turned out that he
was like
a crazy like he would he would whatever
it doesn't matter but the point the
[ __ ] the uh the thing that he did
with us we went up to his house oh this
is what it was it turned out he abused
his mom remember that yeah he went up to
his house in the middle of the [ __ ]
Benedict Canyon or whatever and this
other producer we were with was like is
this weird thing going on with this him
and his mouth I don't know and then
years later it came out that like he was
abusing his mom whoa I barely remember
this anyway okay so
um
like I can just picture him like Ben
Stiller and [ __ ] happy Madison like
oh I'm sorry yeah did you need that you
slap it out of my head and [ __ ] uh
anyway this guy was English he was such
a [ __ ] unbelievable [ __ ] that it
was he was such an unbelievable [ __ ]
that it was funny and I was like you
couldn't take him seriously and it
didn't bother me yeah but it did bother
me he was such and such a such a such a
dick and we were arguing with him again
about something and we were trying to
convey the kind of humor that a certain
scene was supposed to be right because
we were going through the script and and
he was again pushing back on us and he
was like I just don't get it I just
don't get it and and it was getting more
and more tense more and more attention
and then finally uh either you or me was
like you know it's like uh it's like the
style of humor of like Vince Vaughn like
just trying to convey what it is and and
and and and and the guy whose name I'm
not gonna say yeah he he just goes who
the [ __ ] Vince Vaughn and in it we
were like
what yeah yeah like some some kids may
not know who Vince Vaughn is now but
like Vince Vaughn was well we didn't
know what he meant he it was like you
can't not know who Vince Vaughn he meant
but he I don't know if he believed it or
not or I don't know if he would if he
knew him or not but he was trying to act
like he didn't know who he was I
realized that because we asked him
questions afterwards we were like what
you mean like you don't care yes I
remember this the table or you don't
know who he is now who's that who who is
that yeah and he was at this point he
was the biggest comedic actor top five
at least in the [ __ ] country for in
the world for sure really yeah dude yeah
okay maybe Ben Stiller but yeah because
of the Wedding Crashers yeah so so far
insane calling it The Wedding Crashers
that's what it was um Wedding Crashers
The Wedding Crashers no The Wedding
Crashers no it's called Wedding Crashers
The Wedding Crashers I mean okay I'm not
giving it up
Never Gonna Give You Up I'm Never Gonna
Let You Down
The Wedding
what
okay let's do one more here we go oh
[ __ ] you right I know that hey Crystal
so this was the woman that I thought
that was gonna pause it this was the one
that he was gonna play and then he
played that [ __ ] guy he ruined it or
whatever yeah he ruined it yeah okay
another story for you guys uh so
basically I had Investments at this girl
for about eight years we love your stand
up and it has really bonded us over the
years so she she messed with this girl
is what she said
I didn't hear what she said she bonded
with this girl and specifically now over
your company friends with okay okay yeah
got it cool
we decided to get tickets together to go
see you in Lakeland in December so she
bought the tickets on her phone I don't
have the money for my phone for my
ticket and that was our plan we were
gonna go right but recently
not even really recently like most of
our friendship she just continues to
ditch me for guys like she'll cancel our
plans with her current boyfriend or
whatever which is fine if you want to go
hang out with your boyfriend or hang out
with someone else
don't make plans with me yeah don't make
plans me just to cancel yeah that's
waste they waste my time crazy so I
decided to like call around on it and
tell her about it and she just
completely never responded to me never
said anything and instead went and
talked to our other friends about how
I'm
um jealous of her relationship jealous
of her boyfriend I'm just too selfish to
see that she wants to do what she wants
to do and I have to deal with it so
after hearing that I decided to back
away as one would yeah
and then she noticed that I was backing
away and decided to hit me about 10
times harder and removed every single
photo of me ever off all social media
off everything and act like our eight
year best friend relationship just never
even existed so I messaged her and I
said I thought that like I meant a
little bit more to you than if you just
cut me out completely without even a
conversation and she sent me back the
nastiest message I've ever received in
my entire life so I blocked her number
good and then she decided to email me
more nasty things
so needless to say we are no longer
friends yes but the issue is the money
she has my ticket to your show oh and my
money oh no and she won't give it back
what I Emma requested her and she
blocked me on Battle I had other people
found my request her and she's ignoring
it completely and I can't get any of my
stuff back
kick it back so let me know what you
think that's annoying about how I should
go about this if there's any other way
that I can get my money back because
she's basically stealing from me at this
point yeah
um let me know if you know how to get my
[ __ ] back I need to clear this all up
you don't don't respond to this girl
anymore don't right back to her block
her on everything I I moved to Lakeland
was it Lakeland
to January I'm gonna give you two
tickets to Lakeland
for free you don't have to worry about
the money so the the money that she has
now that paid for these tickets that I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna give you two
tickets bring whoever you want bring
your boyfriend bring your [ __ ]
brother bring your friend bring another
friend post all about it have a good
time she'll see it and be like what the
[ __ ] you got two free tickets I think
it's in January it is in January now uh
and if you don't want to go to Lakeland
you want to go somewhere else if it's
closer I'm doing Daytona I'm also doing
Jacksonville let uh the producer know
we'll get you two free tickets so I'll
clear that up right there furthermore
if you did what you said you were doing
it didn't sound like you crossed any
lines to me right no offense to her but
I think she has to be leaving something
out because if here's the thing if
you're not leaving anything out yeah
this is a remarkably crazy person yeah
who you have you should be [ __ ]
thanking your lucky stars that she's not
going to be in your life moving forward
yeah that's that's pretty wild that's
pretty wild if if you're not leaving
anything out you dodged a bullet and
also how are you friends with this
person I know I know this is happening
now some sounds like maybe something
else is going on but also if she anyone
who you block and then they start
emailing you is crazy yeah right like
you blocked her out of look you're
you're really stressing me out you know
it sounds like you're not like hey [ __ ]
you forever it sounds like you're just
like I can't deal with this right now
which is fine it's fine to block for
somebody for a little bit I think
um I I'm all for it uh especially if
it's [ __ ] up your mental health and
[ __ ]
um but uh yeah you uh
yeah you you dodged a a bullet dude uh
so don't worry about the money thing I
got you and then I'm sorry that that
happened
that's not an issue now but also
that's weird is she trying to get her
friends uh
she's just being a crazy person yeah
some people when they feel like they've
been wrong I'm aligned just acts
yeah just act so
crazy
and it's like there's nothing to be done
about it they won't stop it's just like
they're triggered and all of a sudden
they're just a whirlwind of terribleness
Every Which Way oh my yeah terrible all
right uh yes so uh I will be in Lakeland
soon and I will be another but we might
as well have to show up but I will be in
uh Lakeland I will be in Austin I will
be in New York New York I will be in uh
Chicago I will be in Daytona San Diego
Seattle Portland uh Brea California
uh uh Portland yeah I said that uh
Sugarland Texas San Antonio New Orleans
Providence Rhode Island you got it you
got it Springfield Missouri Boise Boise
Cincinnati go to chrisley.com get
tickets Columbus Ohio Columbus Ohio have
you been there no yes but I saw it on
the screen there you go you're very
observant so I'll be there now obviously
click out and go to the other screen so
we can talk about the other things
one-on-one sessions with this dude my
brother mattelia.com I am paying for
that one guy tell him I'll pay you yeah
for the session and then if you have
questions go to watch lifeline.com or if
you want to get that merch for the
holiday season and give it to your
friend lifelinemerch.com that's what's
up and if you want to see it here look
check this out dude look what I'm doing
the secret tips
you're like a superhero superhero
Lifeline man
there we go he's a Lifeline man yep I'll
wear this for next episode love you guys
subscribe get us past
596. see if you might think you're
subscribed and you might not not be able
to show up in my mouth but dude all you
got to do is just subscribe thanks guys
it's like me in the parking lot married
Captain Gallagher
[Music]